Once a mutation has been passed on then
it can spread in the population. So from our
campsite example of the bear, once you survive
and once you produce, more importantly. That allele, that
mutation can get passed on to the next
generation. And the more kids you have the more
you can change the population frequency. So let's focus
on this one particular metric. Allele frequency. We need
some alleles to focus on, so let's go
back to our trusty lactase persistence alleles. We've
learned that there's a lactase persistence allele that's
dominate. Plus here, and a lactase non-persistence allele that's
recessive here, minus. Now let's say I have
a thousand people. 500 are homozygous dominant, 350
are heterozygous, and 150 are homozygous recessive. I
want you to tell me how many total alleles
there are in the population of a thousand people. Go ahead
and enter your answer as a number in the box here.